welcome to this video playing never mind
let's see is some teammate of mine let's
see what we get maybe okay not not the
Stonewall Dutch playing that rather
frequently we get some English let's see
yeah that's a very sharp sharp position
with e five I know d 4 re for really i
didn't know that this was possible
really well probably
hmm ok yeah I'd like to get the pawn
back with Queenie for that's not sure if
I need to do it directly Bishop c5 i
have p should be 3 for example maybe the
night you formed very weird position I
with the burst to seek an castle
actually so maybe I should reconsider
the check and then take care maybe give
the check check give the check first I
can take your right there is no
technical technical thing happening to
me all right least I don't see it at the
moment
looks a bit loose this position here but
c5 is hanging at the moment okay so
maybe I can can go here threatening
Bishop f6 yeah i know i can take here
and you must take you must take the sea
I can take first here on c6 Bishop takes
Bishop f6 GF yeah first take here then
take a6 damaging blacks pawn structure
this should be quite nice if I checked
III I have f4 with a good position at
least 95 also looks looks strongly in he
must take it here and then this is a
very bad structure at five eggs yeah 97
now I thought so yeah wins the exchange
or chat leads to a fantastic position
like this f5 Hanks
they are Queenie 656 rook t6 threatens
brooksie six
yeah very tough to claim rook c8 I can
take f5 it's just it's just yeah I can
take here it's just not playable
disposition blank resigns yeah we'll
have somewhat of an opening disaster
here normally defaults plate but i don't
know maybe e4 as possible as well there
is this this line I cannot take because
of the check and then mostly castles
knight c6 III Jesus's this is known
theoretical line leading to very sharp
play ready I don't know maybe I'm I
really don't know the opening here check
but this already looks nice for white I
mean this pawn advance and gives me the
nice d foursquare I think after this
black already is in slight danger the
computer is already giving white really
big plus 1.6 yeah it's just destroys
black structure losing a pawneean if all
is lost as this is so even worse rook t1
is also good at that this is just as a
simple solution Oh Queenie 525 it was
much easier okay I had seen this exactly
this line and now we as you could see he
cannot castle rook c8 this Queen f5 I
mean this is also winning but I should
have taken the rook of course no nothing
that like like hindu here this really
went terribly wrong quickly maybe maybe
a check here Queen D service maybe an
idea
maybe besides the fact that d 4 is
probably the better line that check
maybe Queen d7 as an idea yeah then I
must go night be five castles Quincy
form looks okay I mean ok for for both
sides nothing nothing special I guess
alright thanks for watching